but eminem um
has obviously put his arm around you man
he's obviously a fan of what you're
doing like
talk about your guys's relationship and
and has it given you any advice or yeah
um so right before um i did the killer
remix forum and we had like an hour and
a half conversation about just life
about music hip-hop all different types
of things
and um
you know just he's always been showing
me genuine love and support very early
on and you know he i appreciate all love
and public support i get because it's
not like you know i'm signed to him you
know so he doesn't have to do that i
don't ever feel entitled for anybody to
show me any love so whatever genuine
love and support i get publicly from any
from fellow peers fellow artists uh
dj's such as yourself
and your platform as well whatever love
i get i really appreciate that
and um i said that to say he was just
showing me a lot of love publicly
and um we had a dope conversation he's
just like man we just got to get some
work in whatever i send you something
and yeah we got to get something in i'm
like bet
and so we probably had that convo like
june 2020 wow and i didn't send him the
record for him to get on until like
february 2021
and because i was just like i was trying
to find a song for him but i was like yo
this is eminem bro it's been like 10
months since
like he told me he got me with a record
i'm like let me just [ __ ] get this
[ __ ] you know like
and not waste that opportunity
and so i knew parables was the one
automatically because his vocal tone fit
that's slim shady all that his vocal
tone fits that perfectly
and um yeah it's a dope thing honestly
were you intimidated um to get on that
remix like did you like like did you did
you write harder does that make sense
like nah nah honestly um
um
he oh you know what i did um i did my
first verse for killer remix right i
sent it over to him and m and i did it
and it was more on some like
three stacks e40 type of flow and then m
called he was like yo i wanted you to be
like a little more like lyrical like on
some rap rap [ __ ] on it i'm like
all right cool like whatever so i re he
had me like redo my verse on some more
rap because at first i just wanted to
because you know that song is more not
like a yeah a rap rap record it's more
of like a vibe sort of thing and so
that's why i gave that he's like i want
you to you know like attack it you know
so i'm like all right cool let's try
that if eminem asks you to redo your
verse you redo your verse for sure a
hundred percent you're like
man if anybody you know on a song i
haven't i haven't ever been asked that
before but um if anybody asked me to
redo it because i asked people to redo
their verses all the time for my song
for my album not all the time but i will
in a heartbeat anyone on this album that
you said hey can you do something
different
no actually everybody was one and done
with this but i've done it before like
like okay i like this one because
i just always want to uh to paint the
best picture whenever you add an artist
to your song or you get added to another
artist's song they already got that
canvas it's like what color palette you
want to add to this
vice versa